Speaker 1: So let's let's now give an example.
We spoke in the last segment about this leaked
memo thanks to Mother Jones.
We learned about this memo in which the Kremlin
is directing Russian media outlets to use
segments of Tucker Carlson's program because
it's absolutely great for them in their goal
of justifying the Russian invasion of Ukraine.
So now Russian state media is being directed
by the Kremlin used clips of Tucker Carlson.
They're doing it.
They love it, OK?
Here is a new sequence of clips from Tucker
Carlson's program.
I believe this was Friday night going going
into the weekend.
Tucker Carlson jumped right into these now
debunked claims about so-called biolabs in
Ukraine.
And Tucker goes right into Joe Biden, is funding
secret biolabs in Ukraine and conducting experiments
on highly dangerous pathogens.
Let's take a look at the clip.
Speaker 3: Last night, we told you that the
Biden administration is funding a number of
secretive bio labs in Ukraine.
Labs that are conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens.
Now, that's not a story, as we told you, we
wanted to do.
In fact, we didn't think it could be true.
It's so over the top and bizarre, and in any
case, the administration had repeatedly and
very aggressively denied that they were doing
anything like this.
And then they attacked anyone who has questions
about it as a tool of Russia.
We foolishly assume that in this one instance,
they might be telling the truth.
Speaker 1: So these claims have been widely
pushed by Russian media.
This is this is like a straight up Russian
propaganda story.
Tulsi Gabbard fell for it.
We're going to talk about that later in the
show.
And it has really worked to shift the narrative
onto something that is not only a distraction,
it's also untrue.
The United States has worked with Ukrainian
labs and labs in all different parts of Europe
and around the world on all sorts of public
health research, which sometimes includes
research on pathogens.
This is not like really a big deal.
There's no conspiracy.
It's not hidden.
It's not unusual.
It's not secret.
The New York Times has a good article on this,
and the right is just loving spreading this
propaganda.
There are biological laboratories in Ukraine.
They've been around nearly 20 years and much
like the U.S. has done to all sorts of institutions
around the world.
The U.S. has provided some funding to a number
of institutions with the goal of researching
pathogens, preventing the production of biological
weapons or knowing how to respond to a potential
bioweapons attack, etc..
The story that Tucker Carlson and the Fox
News milieu and others have misleadingly pushed
is based on some remarks from American officials
that were misinterpreted as proof that the
labs are producing biological weapons or conducting
research on biological weapons.
There is no proof of that, and the U.S. is
certainly not running these labs anyway.
So later in the segment, Tucker Carlson.
He probably knows that the claim that he made
is pretty flimsy.
He moves the goalposts and he ends his monologue
sort of implying.
That even if it's just research on pathogens,
it's by its nature, suspicious it started
about being, you know, bioweapons and weaponized
all this stuff.
So then it's just, well, even if they're just
researching deadly pathogens, that's suspicious
too.
Speaker 3: In fact, the US Embassy in Kiev
has acknowledged joint American and Ukrainian
research and other passenger pathogens such
as hemorrhagic fever virus.
Apparently, there's a lot of this going on
in Ukraine funded by the United States.
Did you know that while Ukraine?
We don't know.
We can only guess now
Speaker 1: by their own stories about the
COVID pathogen research labs.
Remember the whole Wuhan lab story?
That's where it came from.
It was developed their COVID escaped or was
released or whatever by their own claims about
that.
You would think they would realize, well,
research into pathogens isn't suspicious in
and of itself, and it's certainly not unique
to Ukraine.
They're the ones who have been saying it's
going on in Wuhan.
And then the sort of like cherry on top with
this Tucker story is he blinked?
Brings on Glenn Greenwald, who kind of like
a former leftist kind of now just a reactionary.
Tucker brings on Glenn Greenwald as an expert
on detecting deception.
I mean, OK, I don't know about that.
And Glenn Greenwald echoes Tucker Carlson's
completely distorted claims about the bio
labs.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: Last question Maybe you don't know
the answer, but why Ukraine?
You know, of all the countries, you would
conduct this kind of research and you would
pick one with like a solid medical infrastructure.
You'd pick Germany or Israel or someplace
with, you know, first class scientific research
going on.
You would not pick Ukraine while Ukraine.
Unless you viewed Russia as your primary threat
as unless you want it to be provocative toward
the Russians, unless you want it to be in
Ukraine, developing all sorts of weapons as
we clearly have been, we've been flooding
that country with lethal arms for five or
six years.
So clearly there's an intention for the United
States to be heavily involved in Ukraine.
The Russians say their motive is to be threatening
and provocative.
The United States denies that, but they have
their tentacles in Ukraine and have for many
years all the time, which is a critical part
of the narrative that has been lacking.
That's right.
It's fair to ask what have they been doing
in Ukraine?
Why are their kids working for Ukrainian companies?
What is going on here?
Glenn Greenwald, I appreciate you coming on
tonight.
Thank you.
Thanks, Tucker.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, Tucker asks why
Ukraine?
And the reality is they're only talking about
Ukraine, and this is actual Russian propaganda.
Maria Zakharova, spokeswoman for Russia's
Ministry of Foreign Affairs I mean, quite
literally, a Russian propagandist, said on
March 8th.
Ukraine has been concealing traces of a military
biological program supported by U.S. DOD.
The truth is there are 59 labs around the
world that handle deadly pathogens as of a
few months ago and the United States.
The U.S., as part of a consortium which will
later talk about sometimes funds research
that goes on at these labs, there's nothing
unique or special about what's going on in
Ukraine.
And remember that a bio lab and a bio weapons
lab are two very different things, and the
story muddles.
The two makes debunked claims about operational
agreements and funding in all these different
things.
And in the end, it's all meant to run interference
for Putin.
And it doesn't change.
The fact that Putin chose to invade Ukraine
will have some of these clips.
If you've just been listening on our Instagram
at David Pakman show, we'll take a quick break
and be right back.